these fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly zsolnai-fehér not so
long ago google deepmind introduced a
novel learning algorithm that was able
to reach superhuman levels in playing
many Atari games it was a spectacular
milestone in AI research interestingly
while these learning algorithms are
being improved at the staggering pace
there is a parallel subfield where
researchers and ever to break these
learning systems by slightly changing
the information they are presented with
fraudulent tampering with images or
video feeds if you will imagine a system
that is designed to identify what is
seen in an image in an earlier episode
we discussed an adversarial algorithm
wherein an amusing example they added a
tiny bit of barely perceptible noise to
this image to make the deep neural
network miss identify a bus for an
ostrich machine learning researchers
like to call these evil force images
adversarial samples and now this time
around open a I published a super fun
piece of work to fool these game
learning algorithms by changing some of
their input visual information as you
will see in a moment it is so effective
that by only using a tiny bit of
information it can turn a powerful
learning algorithm into a blubbering
idiot
the first method adds a tiny bit of
noise to a large portion of the video
input where the difference is barely
perceptible but it forces the learning
algorithm to choose a different action
that it would have chosen otherwise in
the other one a different modification
was used that have a smaller footprint
for instance in pong adding a tiny fake
ball to the game to course the learner
into going down when it was originally
planning to go up the algorithm is able
to learn game specific knowledge for
almost any other game to fool the player
despite the huge difference in the
result
I love the elegant mathematical
formulation of the two noise types
because despite the fact that they do
something radically different their
mathematical formulation is quite
similar mathematicians like to say that
we are solving the same problem while
optimizing for different target nodes
beyond these mind speed cue learning too
other high-quality learning algorithms
are also fooled by this technique in the
white box formulation we have access to
the inner workings of the algorithm but
interestingly a black box formulation is
also proposed where we know much less
about the target system but we know the
game itself and we train our own system
and look for weaknesses in depth when we
found these weak points we use this
knowledge to break other sisters I can
only imagine how much fun there was to
be had for the authors when they were
developing these techniques super
excited to see how this arms race of
creating more powerful learning
algorithms and in response more powerful
adversarial techniques to break them
develops in the future I feel that the
robustness of the learning algorithm or
in other words its resilience against
adversarial attacks will be just as
important of a design factor as how
powerful it is there are a ton of videos
published on the author's website make
sure to have a look and also if you wish
to support the series make sure to have
a look at our patreon page we kindly
thank you for your contribution it
definitely helps keeping the series
running thanks for watching and for your
generous support I'll see you next time
[Music]
Oh